So to jump right
into things, I'm
going to ask a few questions.
And then if it applies to you,
we're going to clap twice.
So clap twice if you've
ever written a Shiny app.
Sweet, awesome.
That's a lot of you.
Good! All right.
Clap twice if you remember
all of your app's features.
(no, or very few, claps)
Okay... and then...
Clap twice if you would feel
comfortable having a coworker
rewrite part of your app.
(no, or very few, claps)
Ah, still not a lot of
you, but most of us
feel about our
apps, it's our precious,
We don't want anyone
else to touch it.
So this gives is like,
as Sydeaka was saying,
with automated testing as well.
And having other working
with team members,
this brings a big
motivation to have something
with automated testing.
So that we don't lose
our app features.
Or we could have a coworker
at work on a new feature
and not have it destroy
your existing features.
And so we'll get into
this throughout today.
All right.
So to make sure everyone's
on the same page,
even though there's
lots of claps, what is Shiny.
So Shiny allows you
to quickly build
full stack interactive
web applications.
And it does this
in very few lines.
I believe, for you to do
this in other languages,
it would take a lot of work.
And it does this by executing
reactive expressions
within the server and the server,
when you change one
of these reactive values,
all downstream reactions (are)
invalidated.
And then they must
be recalculated.
And this is how we can do
a lot of our reactivity
within Shiny.
And as Sydeaka said, there's
this very familiar workflow
within Shiny.
It's where we're going to
tweak some of the apps
we're going to add and adjust
some of that reactivity,
we'll then click
Run app and then -
this is why we love R -
that we manually look at it.
We can manually
iterate on this and we
can do this every 30
seconds, 10 seconds
even, if you're really quick.
And that's why we love
R. (With) JavaScript,
it might be 10 hours if you want
to add a new feature. With R,
if you know the commands it could
just be a few seconds.
And that's great.
But, what if you have 20 apps?
What if you have
many team members?
What if you have things
where you can't quite keep it
all in your head at once?
And with manually experimenting,
things are lost in translation.
Can you explain to your
coworker all of your features
and have them make sure they
manually test it properly?
Like, I don't believe
I could do that.
And I'm very familiar
with the infrastructure.
And so it kind of
crumbles once you
start doing more than
just toy applications.
And Gimli says there's no
chance of success.
So this kind of opens the
door to a different package.
And this is the
"test that" package.
The "test that"
package is typically more
from the package development
world of and it performs
unit testing for R
And this is where it executes
formal unit test such as "expect
equal" or "expect greater than".
And I think this is great.
You can build your
whole test suite
and then build out
your functionality
to try to pass that test suite.
I remember having many
situations where we might
try to build out 100 tests.
Then let's build those methods
to try to pass those tests.
Test-driven development.
And its goals are
four main goals.
Number one, to have fewer bugs.
If you're constantly
testing things,
then things get broken
less often because you're
very aware of what's going on.
You can also have more robust
code because maybe you're
testing for chicken fingers.
That's not something that would
automatically test by default
during my manual test.
If you have better code
structure as you're
breaking your functions down.
If you test each LEGO
piece of your code,
then when you put all that
together, you can believe
that you have a strong
code structure at the end,
very robust because you
know, each component
is doing very well.
And then finally you
have call to action.
Right now, I am getting
very little sleep.
I have a new baby boy.
And it's wonderful having
call to action because -
Oh, Thank you -
It's like you can
set in a broken test
and say, like, fix
this in the morning
and then you don't need that
45 minutes kind of warm up
for the day.
You can kind of jump back in
because you
had that test while you were
deep into your coding session.
So let's take a look at "test that"
and kind of see what an example is.
I talked about
those formal tests.
This would be like
expect equal where
we can do our standard,
basic test, 2 times 2.
Does it equal four?
Yes, great.
Kind of a non-standard one.
Make it a little
bit more robust.
2 times NA that's an NA
integer, if you do NA regular,
that's actually illogical
and it would fail
without the underscore integer.
And then new to "test that"
edition 3 is snapshot testing.
Snapshot testing
is where we don't
do an expect equal x to y.
We say kind of keep
track of this file
and then just make
sure it doesn't change
because that file may
contain lots of content that
can't be put into code.
So we can make an
example file and then
we can say expect
snapshot file from "test
that" and it will compare
to, say, did the file change
from each run, Yes or No.
And if it didn't,
then the test passed.
So if we run devtools
test within the IDE,
you can see that those three
tests pass very quickly.
And you get a
success and "test that"
does a wonderful job
of encouragement.
But that was a bad ass code.
You test over and over again.
Get a new random message every
(inaudible)
So I'd like to take
these two worlds
and combine them into one.
And here's what
we'll get: shinytest2.
The shinytest2 is unit
testing for Shiny applications.
But I actually want to adjust
that a little bit, because it's
very difficult to write
all of the unit tests
and then fill in the logic.
Instead, it's more regression
testing for Shiny applications.
In that you have
existing app behavior
and you've seen this through
your own manual testing.
And you don't want to lose this.
Typically we do something
like three hours of work
and I want to make
sure that you don't
lose that three hours of work.
So we're going to insert
a test and make sure
that behavior does not
regress, or does not go away.
It executes within "test that",
so there's a framework
that we're all hopefully
very familiar with.
And it should be very
natural as to what happens.
In shinytest, the
extra helper methods
that exist within
there, they all
leverage to "test
that" snapshot file.
So there's nothing special
that shinytest is doing.
It's just kind of
orchestrating everything
into a nice place packed.
And then, especially
important, it's
built on chromote, which uses
your local chromium based
browser, typically Chrome,
and allows you to execute
headless browser tests.
So it doesn't need to open up.
It can execute just
as GitHub action
or even hidden in your terminal.
But one of the
beautiful things is
that you can view that
live test application.
And I'll show a
demo of that later.
And then also because
it's Chrome, you
can have your familiar
debugging tools
that Chrome provides and
those are very, very powerful.
So elephant in the room.
What about
Shinytest?
If you are familiar with it,
it's entering maintenance mode.
The headless browser
has been set on end
of life for a few years now.
PhantomJS
is not really usable.
I actually would argue
it is worse than IE,
and IE has already
been killed by Microsoft.
And also Shiny is
moving towards wanting
to have everyone use
Bootstrap 5 and it is not
Bootstrap 5 compatible.
So it is impossible
to do these tests.
So shinytest2,
also, it has a different
headless browser.
So all of your prior
screenshots, if you had them,
they would be a failure.
And that's not something that
I want to introduce on everyone.
Also because of "test that"
we have a different file
structure,
and since we had the
opportunity we also
streamlined the API to leverage
test that, as well as a different
R API. Well that's why
there's two different.
So before we get into
some deeper code,
let's look at a very small
toy example, Shiny app.
And what it's going to do,
it's going to ask your name.
We're then going
to greet that name
and then we should have
a response or a greeting.
I'll insert my name
Barrett and click greet.
It'll say "Hello, Barrett!"
That's it.
Very, very complicated.
I know.
But it's nice because
we have a text input,
we have an action button
and we also have a text out.
These are very common components
within your Shiny application,
and they may be located in
very different locations,
but these are a good
example of what's happening.
If I was to set
that up as a test,
we would need to set up
our own "test that" code.
So we would say "test that"
the app says "hello Barrett",
and this is in the file there.
And if we were to insert
some shinytest2 to code,
you don't need to
know it exactly.
But we can kind of
walk through it.
We're here inside the test,
we will set up our AppDriver.
This is the thing that
kind of orchestrates
everything - gets chromote going,
get your Shiny app going
and then it handles
all the interactions.
And then we tell the
app, hey, set the input
and say name is Barrett.
Then when that's all done,
click the greet button and then
when everything has
been done as well,
say expect values
because I want make
sure my input and output are
consistent.
And I think it's
just so beautiful
that in four lines of code, I
set up the app, set some input
and make expectations.
And it's not a crazy thing.
So let's run that
test because we
want to run these tests
over and over and rapidly,
constantly. In real time.
Took a few seconds.
Not too bad.
Now, your three hours of work
that you kind of worked on
is now captured in being able
to replay in a few seconds.
Make sure that
work is never lost.
"But writing tests is hard."
says everyone but Hadley.
The good news is, is there's
a method called record test.
And I think this is
great because you don't
need to write those tests.
So we can capture all of
the Shiny interactions
and then record that as a "test
that" test.
And I really want to stress this
because I love the McDonald's
quote of "if you have time to
clean, you have time to clean."
But in this case, "if
you have time to rest,
you have time to record a test."
And this is because
recording these tests
is not that long when you
do your manual testing.
It takes just a few
seconds, 10 seconds.
This whole gif here
is just 10 seconds.
So it's a very
familiar greeting.
We do the interactions.
And then I click the
values and I save and exit.
That's it. The 10 seconds
for me to go in,
do the manual
manipulations that I want,
I then save my Shiny values
or expect my Shiny values
and I save it.
And I think it's just great.
And all of your app
will live on the side
and you can see your code update
as to what being generated.
And then when we're all done
after next, at least one
expectation made, then we save.
Great that code
that was recorded,
this is actually what is stored.
So I didn't doctor this one and
it is oddly similar to the one
that we looked at before.
Just the only difference
is the test name
is just saying that
it's the recording.
Let's look at that
testing we want.
I want to know that always
run your DevTools run these
faster like constantly, because
they are fast and quick.
Not too bad.
And I want to make sure
that you don't lose any.
But remember earlier
I was talking
about how we had chromote.
And in chromote you can view your
headless browser.
If you're familiar
with Shiny tests.
It was a black box.
Could only poke it from
the outside and pray.
There is not much you could do.
With our apps, they are getting
more and more complicated,
and that's awesome.
It's wonderful to see.
But if it's a
headless browser, it
means you can't see it like
our regular browsers today,
but chromote allows
you to view it.
So there's method you
can run interactively.
Called app$
or $view.
And this is what it will.
So in this gif...I have
the test on the right
that I'm running
interactively in my console.
And what we'll do is we
will library(shinytest2)
I will then run my AppDriver
working directory app;
I'll app$view.
And this will open up Chrome
browser on your screen.
You can see the app there and
you can, on the right side,
you can also see all
of your familiar
Chrome debugging tools.
Just great.
And also see your console at the
bottom, shinytest will spit
out some information about
what's happening.
<inaudible> if
I call set_input,
you can see the app update live.
It didn't have to do anything,
you didn't have to refresh.
And when we click greet
it actually updated
live you see the output
there. I think that is
just so powerful because you
can be like: "why is
this test not working?"
Run, run, run, run.
Insert an app$view in the console,
then be exactly where it's at
and you know your app and you'll be
able to discover what's wrong.
Whereas shinytest2 you can
only tell you what's going on.
So I have some suggestions
as you leave the Shiny Shire
and you are on your way to
testing.
#1 is to use
shiny::exportTestValues()
This is a method that I
was actually unaware of.
I'm on the Shiny
team and I really
want to give it more limelight
because it is very powerful.
We don't need to test
just inputs and outputs.
There's actually a third
group called Export
and you can export
react values.
You can export your
reactive value,
and it doesn't need to be
an input or something that
has been rendered as an output.
This is great
because testing mode
and will allow for
this to work and you
can expose more information
and more working logic that
doesn't need to be in your normal
app that you use day to day.
Also try to limit objects
under your own control.
If you do something like a
data structure and then you
send it into DT and DT
updates because it needs to.
Nothing wrong with DT doing
that, but your output
might change, which would
produce false positives.
So maybe just test your
data frame going in
and then just trust
that DT will always render.
Another one is, again, if
you use expect snapshot file,
be careful about what's going
on with those snapshots.
All the snapshot does is
says, I agree with myself,
but it doesn't mean
that it's correct.
So you need to at
least manually confirm
that snapshot is correct.
And then if you do agree with
yourself, you are correct.
So that's good.
But there's that little
logical loophole.
Be safe.
You can always use
manual expectations,
or explicit expectations,
such as expect equal because that
will always be truthful,
if you're comparing it to a static.
And then lastly,
minimize the number
of screen shots expectations.
Screenshots are worth
a thousand tests.
They do test everything,
but you can also
imagine that's a very high false
positive rate with 1,000 tests.
And so they're very
brittle, they're
open to a lot of issues.
Also you cannot
compare across operating
systems or R versions.
So it gets very
unwieldy very quickly.
So unless screenshots
are absolute,
I would argue maybe not do that.
So recap shinytest2: regression
testing for your app.
You want to keep that
behavior over time.
If you have time to rest, you
have time to record a test.
And then interactively view your
application whenever possible
if you run into trouble.
And hopefully Gandalf
will change his tune
from you shall not pass to...
You Pass.